les téléfilms et les films de noël sont
depuis quelques semaines déjà à la fiche
d après-midi du petit écran les
plateformes de streaming bien évidemment
surf aussi sur cette vague
bonjour célia 10 nous pourquoi ces films
de noël et téléfilms de noël sont autant
à la mode
la pluie qui tombe un chocolat chaud à
la main enroulé dans un groupe led et et
bien sûr un bon film de noël de
nombreuses yvelinois apprécient ce genre
d'après midi ou de soirée avait juste
avant les fêtes de fin d'année et de
quoi et bien anticipé la magie de noël
c'est l'esprit de noël c'est c'est plein
de bonheur les gens sont contents
le dîner de famille et cadeaux c'est une
fois par an donc on en profite mois de
décembre c'est l'ambiance que ça crée
l'ambiance que ça suscite ça mais dans
justement l'ambiance qui a donc un peu
chaleureuse familiale
ça donnait envie de regarder c'est
plutôt positif
après une année difficile comme celle là
alors malheureusement les cinémas sont
fermés mais les télés télévision et
plateformes de streaming donc qui sont
mis aussi et depuis quelques semaines
déjà
oui dès le 2 novembre alors soit
quasiment un mois al avance
le scénario est quasiment toujours le
même un personnage d'une grande ville
est de passage dans une petite ville qui
porte les valeurs de noël
et puis souvent se mêle une histoire
d'amour et c'est souvent plusieurs fois
par jour que fait certains sont proposés
ces 77 téléfilm de noël ont été diffusés
en une foule mais tous regarder non jeu
car votre wii et les audiences sont là
alors bien sûr le confinement est passée
par là mais en fait les téléfilms de
noël ont un large public
il pèse aussi bien aux jeunes qu'aux
seniors et puis les plateformes donc de
streaming s'y mettent aussi
netflix amazon prime disney plus tous
proposent leurs créations originales et
en tant que spécialiste vous avez
forcément des conseils à nous donner
oui alors demandons d'abord aux
yvelinois quelle est leur film de noël
préféré l'étrange noël de monsieur
scrooge un noël de princesse le grinch
c'est vraiment un film classique
alors oui le grinch c'est le film de
noël le plus populaire d'ailleurs remake
est sorti en 2018 c'est une créature en
fait pour résumer qui déteste noël et
veut gâcher cette fête en volant tous
les cadeaux mais finalement il va se
rendre compte que l'esprit de noël ne se
résume pas à ça bon petit lot de leur
père
et dans d'autres styles vous avez
l'étrange noël de monsieur jack
joyeux noël ou encore klaus et dans et
d'autres plus connus et moins récents
maman j'ai raté l'avion ou encore le
célèbre film que français qui revient
chaque année c'est le père noël est une
ordure ciel est gris mais une société
qui se déroule à noël on en parle dans
cette émission faut pas oublier celui ci
dans un style un peu différent également
votre coup de coeur alors montré d'abord
avec les game means no lo green savoir
mes films préférés restent love actually
à leur robinet c'est un film culte
réalisé par richard curtis film sorti en
2003 mais le dise histoire d'amour entre
romance désillusion rencontres
inattendues
le tout dans une ambiance de noël love
actually a été diffusée sur m6 ce jeudi
dernier jeudi 10 décembre et à
rassembler encore plus de 2 millions de
téléspectateurs
et pour ceux qui ne l'auraient pas vu il
est encore disponible sur netflix et
amazon presse qu'il faudrait leur voir
et le revoir et la roma encore en
général voilà c'est ça fonctionne comme
ça merci célia